ihr solltet rausgehen und wählen wählt
und sagt euren senatoren was ihr denkt
geht jetzt kannst du die klappe halten
man so etwas gab es vorher noch nie
gesagt du bist an die dello stato nie
gegangen aber du hast den namen des
college es vergessen bei deinem
abschluss warst du der schlechteste oder
fast der schlechteste des jahrgangs
verwenden nicht das wort klug in meiner
gegenwart verschont mich nichts an die
es klug joe dewhurst 47 jahre lang
nichts gemacht
das land hätte mehr davon wenn beide
reden könnten und weniger unterbrochen
würden ich bitte sie sich daran zu
halten mir aber auch na ja ehrlich
gesagt haben sie mehr unterbrochen er
aber auch viel das ist weniger als sie